foreign
let's go out to Phoenix and talk to
Emily hey Emily what's up
hey hey John
um so my question is about
how do I allow myself or how do I have a
healthy relationship after living a life
for over eight years in an abusive
marriage
I view the world through that lens and I
just don't know how to
have a relationship at this point yeah
no kidding anymore
um what kind of abuse tell me about it
or what you feel safe telling me about
um there's a lot of stuff I probably
can't say on a show but um it was
everything you can you can say whatever
you want to say say whatever you want to
say
um Financial abuse emotional abuse
sexual abuse it was
pretty much everything he just never
crossed the line enough for you know
authorities to get involved
so let me back out he crossed every
single line
yeah he said I don't want you to ever
think that
well he didn't do it that bad he did
yeah right and you know that you know
that
um
the courts don't see that but I yeah I
know yeah I know it's heartbreaking
sometimes
um it's heartbreaking a lot of times
um
so my guess is you've tried to date
since then and it has not gone well tell
me about that
I am in a relationship and have been for
just over a year okay
um he's a great guy but everything that
he does is I call a red flag even if
it's not you know I I just view
everything through the lens of trauma
and feel like you know it's always going
to come bite me
you know some like I'm missing something
you know has he bit you yet this new guy
has he what has he bit you yet not
really but you know what I mean I know
no no there there's there's been nothing
there's just things that I say to myself
well maybe that's something and I'm
missing it okay
so trauma works by taking you away from
yourself right disassociating you from
yourself
and
foreign
job is to make sure that never happens
again ever
right your body's just doing what it's
supposed to do
so your body's put
um try to say this as easy as I can your
body put a GPS pin
and love your body put a GPS pin in men
and said this situation this this bear
nearly killed this last time I'm gonna
get your attention every single time
we're around a bear
and so the goal of trauma healing is to
reconnect you with yourself
and to teach your body that you weren't
unsafe you I mean you weren't safe then
but you're safe now
and the scary part about that is in
relationship it's always vulnerable so
you're always going to be mostly safe
all right that's the worst part of it
yeah
um even last night I'm talking to my
wife and I said some very vulnerable
things and she could have said you're
such a baby oh my gosh I thought I
married a Texan I didn't realize that
she could have done that
and I would have had to deal with the
hurt of them she didn't
all right so it was vulnerable last
night I was nervous to say what I was
gonna say so it's always gonna be a part
of any sort of romantic relation any
relationship father daughter
um father son parent anything work
relationship and especially romantic
there's always going to be that
vulnerability what you have to decide is
when that red flag comes up
and your bodies get your attention and
says hey
think we're missing something here
are you going to challenge that thought
or are you gonna run with it
how do you challenge it though because I
seem to just run with it
have you ever taken the time to write
some of these red flags down on a piece
of paper and actually stare at them and
say is this true
um not really it's a painful long
exercise and worth every second
because what you're going to do is he's
going to get home and he's going to be
texting somebody on his phone and he's
going to drop his phone face down
and your body's gonna go see told you
he's cheating I knew it
right there that's the moment you can't
help that lightning bolt that lightning
bolt is your brain's job or he comes in
and you feel he's angry and you want to
hide in the cabinets
that feeling that lightning bolt get out
now Emily go go go
that lightning bolt is real and true and
you can't really stop that initially
over time your body learns but in the
moment you can't what you do is have a
choice in that moment
to say is this true
and when he turns his phone over just
drops it because he's a goofball and he
has to go to the bathroom and he had a
long commute home and you go is he
cheating on me no
he's not
right and that's one of those moments
sometimes I used to put my hand on my
chest like is my wife really hate me
and I would be like no she doesn't
do I wish that she had just come in and
be like oh my gosh I'm so happy to see
you and give me a big hug I wish that
yes
does she hate me though no
that I would literally practice dropping
my shoulders
and what I would not do is I would not I
would fight it and I would fight it and
I would fight it I will not have these
imaginary conversations
I'm not going to let the person who used
to hurt me
continue to speak into my present
relationships where somebody's trying to
love me
and that's just something you got to
practice
I'll also say there may be some trauma
counseling that you need to go deal with
and train trauma counselors those
trained in the works of Peter Levine and
Van Der kolk and some of them use
Bodywork EMDR it's amazing but they do
it's incredible what they do
and so it's you saying let me take some
time and go be well and really in a we
in a strange way I don't understand how
it works I'm sure there's some
neuroscientists that can figure it out
for me or some polyvagal scientific have
figured out for me your nervous system
just control deletes it it it it just
goes it's like a it's a piece that I
can't describe other than I've I've been
through it and it feels like almost
almost like a depressive State because
my body's been running so hot for so
long
when you start to feel comfortable and
at peace and a little bit safe
is that when the symbols start crashing
the loudest
yeah
it is yeah
I think that's your body's last ditch
effort to keep you out of something that
almost got you last time
yeah
give me one example of something you'd
like to be different
one story that keeps spinning up that
you would like to to work on
as far as my current relationship
yeah
um I feel like he's secretive okay on a
lot of things and I lived that with my
ex-husband and he was secretive for a
reason he was
doing a lot that he shouldn't have been
doing
so
if I'm you
I would feel absolutely comfortable
sitting down and I'm saying that
jokingly there's no way I'd feel
comfortable doing what I'm gonna tell
you to do but um I would feel
comfortable sitting down saying hey I
was married before that guy hurt me real
bad
and I really like you
and also my body runs pretty hot the the
the antenna is pretty hot
and so I'm gonna have to practice and
learn to trust you
and it feels to me like you're being
super secretive what are can you tell me
about that and he might say can you give
me some examples of how I'm being
secretive so I'll ask you that what are
some examples of how he's being
secretive
um he's very secretive with his phone
okay all right making sure I don't see
passcodes and you know things like that
have you said that and said I'm
uncomfortable with the fact that I don't
know the passcode to your phone
I have not why not
um because again I view it through my
previous relationship and I know how
that went with him so I'm just it's
like I don't want to fight about it
what if it's nothing if it's nothing
then who cares
you know what I mean if it's nothing who
cares
who cares at all
yeah I guess I'm afraid I'm going to
push him away because of my insecurity
and my trust issues and
what happened to you in the past
happened to you in the past and anybody
who loves you is going to know
this person is going to need an extra
ounce of
um
trust displaying
and that's okay
this person who I'm growing to love who
I want to date
um man got hurt bad and I'm gonna be so
above board so that she can breathe and
she can lean into this new relationship
I think you have to come to the place
where if you said hey
you're super secretive with your phone
and I I lived this for almost a decade a
guy who would never let me see the code
of his phone who would always hide his
phone and it ended up blowing up all
over me
I'm not comfortable being in another
romantic relationship or we have secrets
like that
and if he said well screw you if you
don't trust me I'm out of here I'm gonna
tell you Emily it's gonna hurt real bad
but you dodged another bullet
and if he laughs and says okay here you
go and it's a bunch of crude jokes
between him and some of the guys he
works with you can say you're gross
and move on about your day you see what
I'm saying
I do I do but I feel like oh man
this is easy for me to say I'm an old
married man right
but I want to tell you you're worth more
than hedging what you feel
I want to tell you Secrets will kill you
and can I tell you something kind of
hard ah I feel bad saying this but not
really
you're being secretive too
you can see that you're not telling him
the truth either
yeah because the truth is you think
something's freaky going on let me tell
you one more thing about trauma it does
really finely tune your radar sometimes
and sometimes it can overtune it to
where you see trauma everywhere and
there's not actually you're dating
somebody new that's great
it also though can catch before you even
realize it oh that is cheating 100
cheating I feel it
and so I want to tell you part of
getting reconnected with yourself and it
sounds like such lofty floofy language I
get that
it's learning to trust your gut again
the only way to learn to trust your gut
against to have gut instincts and act on
them I feel in my bones there's
something on that phone that you're
hiding from me
can I see it do you love me enough do
you trust me enough because if not we've
been together for a year we probably
need to have a different conversation
or if they go of course here
there you go
and by the way if
um
somebody's cleaning
like someone's
folding your underwear and putting in a
drawer they should be able to see your
phone
if y'all are sharing
DNA and you make kids together y'all
should be able to share phones for God's
sakes
having this eternal private life that is
separate
um having private thoughts having
private journals all that's good I mean
that's you working through yourself
having this private Universe I can get
real dicey real real fast I know because
I've been there you can get dicey real
fast
so that's just what let me say this
Emily you're not crazy
you're not crazy I would probably if I
was you if you're my mom if you're my
sister
um I would tell you go spend some time
with a trauma counselor who's trained
because you got some healing you need to
do I think you need to be very honest
with yourself about the behaviors that
you are finding that are setting off all
of your body's alarms
in your current relationship reminding
you of the past and I don't think you
just wipe those away as well this
happened back then because they may be
happening right now again
that may be happening right now again
I'm gonna send you a copy of my brand
new book building a non-anxious life I
want you to work through all those
exercises and begin to look at your life
and say no no here's the places where
without even thinking about it I was
choosing an anxious existence I was
doing this unintentionally I was doing
this unintentionally I was doing this
unintentionally and I've created a life
of chaos and I'm done with it
I'm done with it
hang on the line we'll get you hooked up
call anytime
you're not crazy
I'm so sorry that somebody hurt you
you're worth so much more